angry pigs
[Music]
angrier hairier pigs when are you gonna
kill a bear on abroad in japan
yeah you did half the process there you
should have done it yourself
okay
i don't think that'd last very long to
be honest my track record
well i mean because you wait because how
did you have the beer
did you hear about that brown bear that
like took on a military base in hokkaido
yeah who won it's like a terminator
this bear went on a rampage through
hokkaido and it started going into a
military base
and they'd take it down it's like a
[ __ ] hollywood movie
the japanese
the brown bears are terrifying like they
just eat people like a whole campsite
got eaten once
people sleeping there comes a
well-coordinated
without someone running away on the
mainland we have black pairs and
you know people punch them in the face
when they attack what there's a story of
like a
someone an old woman working an old man
working at an aomori
apple orchard and this man was like
the bells are [ __ ] and around because
the the nose is like the weak spot yeah
so if you just punch it then like
the bear's just like oh what the [ __ ] is
this kind of small but the brown bears
you did that they'd rip your [ __ ]
arms
so these they made like a death star
weakness on the the black bears
poke it and they're just [ __ ] pretty
much effective
just to get a pencil and they're [ __ ]
terrified
[Laughter]
be careful yeah that's scary
what is he laughing about bears be
careful
this is why we just which is just
fantastic advice from chrissy
nice just wondering yes be careful
next time i'll lure it into an acid
sulfuric bath
and see how the bear likes it